>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Michael Cavna: Well thank you.
So, we're gonna bring out
our next cartoonist now.
As she designed the festival poster,
so if you've seen her drawings
big all around, you know, it.
[ Applause ]
She grew up in Brooklyn and ended up
at the Rhode Island School of Design
and she landed at The
New Yorker in the 70s
when she said they're just
weren't that many women cartoonists
and she enters this field
and now, all this time later,
she has been described
as the rock star
of The New Yorker among
the cartoonists.
She, on top of all her other books,
she came out several
years ago the Memoir
About Eldercare, a brilliant memoir.
It's called Yes.
It's called, Can't We Talk
About Something More Pleasant?
It won the Kirkus prize
at the National Book
Critics Award Recognition
and it won the Heinz
award, which I think came
with maybe quarter million
dollars or something like that?
So that will sustain a
cartoonist a little while longer.
She also recently won the Reuben
award we have with us in Roz
and Anne, two of the last
three Reuben award winners
so we're blessed with that and
that's the [inaudible] Society.
If not, so, I can't
recommend more highly,
Can't We Talk About
Something More Pleasant?
if you haven't read it and I just
posted last week a piece that's
on the post site, it's a
love letter about New York.
It comes out in October.
I can't recommend highly enough
another memoir Going into Town.
Please welcome Roz Chast.
[ Applause ]
Yeah, I just I want to step back
and say I think it was a Small
Press Expo some years back,
you took me aside and you
said I have a story in me.
My parents have died and
I have something to say.
I didn't know what to expect
and you come out with this book
and it just blew me away and we were
talking about writing from reality,
but what was it like for you to
plumb into reality so deeply?
>> Roz Chast: I think I felt that
I really wanted to tell this story
for a lot of different reasons.
One was that my parents really
were very unique and I felt
like that whole, my
parents were born in 1912.
They were a lot older than most
of my friend's parents and I felt
like there were a lot of things
about that whole generation
that was just fading away, but also,
as I said to my editor, you know,
this really should be, maybe should
be shelled in the travel section,
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah.
>> Roz Chast: because I
felt like this was a country
that I was visiting that
I didn't even know existed
and never mind never having
been there, but, you know,
as I said in the book, I thought,
you know, from what I had read
and all the books I've read
and from movies I'd seen,
that people got really old and
then maybe like they were sick
for like three weeks
they take to their bed,
you know, that's what happens.
They take to their bed, and then
and then there's a death rattle.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah
>> Roz Chast: And then they
die, you know, And I didn't know
that it could be that dying was
this incredibly long protract,
excuse me I just got
extremely distracted.
Somebody is holding
up a sign that says,
"say goodbye to Mike and Anne,"
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah.
>> Roz Chast: So, bye Mike and Anne.
>> Michael Cavna: No,
they're up here, not no, just,
>> Anne: Can we leave?
>> Michael Cavna: No, we're
gonna have one more question.
>> Roz Chast: Sorry.
I just, alright, alright.
>> Michael Cavna: They're
giving away all my stage tricks.
>> Roz Chast: Oh, I'm
sorry, I'm sorry.
[laughing]
>> Michael Cavna: So, you know,-
>> Roz Chast: Have a good trip.
[laughing]
>> Michael Cavna: Speaking of dying
with a death rattle, protracted,
>> Roz Chast: Sorry.
Sorry. I got so serious.
[laughing]
>> Michael Cavna: No, I did have
one thing, before we say goodbye
to Mike and Anne, [laughing]
>> Mike: What if we don't go?
>> Roz Chast: I miss them.
I miss them already.
>> Michael Cavna: I know, I feel
like they were just with us.
>> Roz Chast: I know, I know.
>> Michael Cavna: There are
doors that are supposed to open.
>> Roz Chast: I know, I know.
>> Michael Cavna: No, what I did
want to get to, you talk to me
and we talked about in the 70s,
you went to a New Yorker party
and it was men who were,
they were even your style,
your style they were somehow
that your style and it was tied
up with being female and all this
and they were, who is this young,
you know, you were about 24 who
is this young woman interloper?
And I've talked to Dan
about how there's still
so few women political cartoonists
out there and so unfairly
or not you kind of have
to be symbols for it.
For kind of standing
for women in your field.
Is it gotten old yet?
Do you feel empowered yet?
Can you talk about that?
>> Anne: Well, I mean, I know
that I don't want to speak
for all my female editorial
cartooning colleagues,
but we think of ourselves
as editorial cartoonists.
>> Michael Cavna: Yes.
>> Anne: I mean sure,
we do women's issues
and I think we bring obviously
a very good, you know,
perspective about it but, you know,
I we're editorial cartoonist
that's what we do.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah, and
there's no, unlike what Roz talked
about in the 70s or 60s, sort of you
don't fit male peers you haven't run
across male peers in
your industry who have,
>> Anne: Dismissed?
>> Michael Cavna: Dismissed.
>> Anne: Oh sure.
[laugh] Yeah but, you
know, the more you're in it
and the longer you're there you
get more respect and you can,
you know, slap them around a bit.
>> Michael Cavna: There you go.
Have you been slapped around?
>> Roz Chast: No, no I just kind
of like get a sad look on my face.
Prefer what my mother used to
call the psychological, you know,
give him the silent treatment.
>> Michael Cavna: Wow.
>> Roz Chast: No, I think
that for me it was really,
mostly the older people and, you
know when people have asked me
about being a female
cartoonist at the New Yorker,
especially when I was younger,
I always say that is
one of so many problems,
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah.
>> Roz Chast: you know, I was,
it was being, I mean it was 23
when I started as being like
20 years younger than a lot
of these-than the youngest
of those people.
Being female, my work
looked totally different,
it was a different sensibility,
so it was just one star
in the constellation of
like we don't like you.
[laughs]
>> Michael Canva: Yeah,
Well now you're the Rockstar
of that constellation.
>> Roz Chast: [Groans]
>> Michael Canva: Well it's true.
Well, you may not have noticed,
but it's time to say
goodbye to Mike and Anne.
[laughs]
>> Roz Chast: Goodbye.
>> Michael Canva: Thank you, guys.
[ Applause and laughs ]
>> Roz Chast: Oh, these
Mike and Anne?
I thought it was maybe like
somebody else in the audience.
Bye.
>> Mike: [Inaudible]
Can I just tell you one
of my favorite cartoons I've
ever seen in my life was yours
and it was a woman reading a
newspaper and it was the obits.
And it was a person's name and
then it says, "older than you,"
and it said, "younger than you,
about your age, a lot
older than you."
Because I don't know that's
the way I read the obits.
[ Laugh and applause ]
>> Michael Canva: So, I think
that the death rattle is
going to come up a lot.
But I want to make sure to get
to your images but, you know,
one thing that we talked about was,
you know, you are growing up here,
and it was Flatbush, right?
>> Roz Chast: Yes.
>> Michael Canva: The
cleverest part of Brooklyn.
Represented.
And so, you grew up with your
parents, you have relatives around,
you're in a tiny bedroom and you,
I think I asked you if you hated it
and hate with such a mild term
for how you felt about growing up.
Could you talk about that?
>> Roz Chast: Well
Doctor, [laughs] yeah,
I remember that overhead
lights it was, [laughs].
Yeah, it was just a
different era, you know.
I guess. So yeah.
[laughs] We're clearly
going to switch topics here.
>> Michael Canva: Ok,
[laughs] well let's start with,
>> Roz Chast: Ah, yes.
>> Michael Canva: Can
they get that one up?
>> Roz Chast: I don't
think it's up yet.
>> Michael Canva: No, it's
not on there but well,
this is when moms dance
and yes so there we go.
[laughs]. So how much
like real life?
>> Roz Chast: This cartoon was
actually inspired by my daughter
when she was around sixteen, and
if you've ever been a teenager
or had teenage children, you know,
that there's almost nothing
more disgusting in the sight
of a teenager's eyes and the adult
human body, [laughs] and which,
I don't totally disagree with,
but, if you really want to gill
that Lily, just do a little dance.
[Laughs] And so, my daughter
was in the living room
and she was doing her homework
and she had some hip-hop music on
and I just wanted to see if
she was paying attention.
So, I did this little
dance and she looked up
and she said mom stop,
you're hurting me.
And I asked her if I
could use it as a cartoon.
And she said okay.
>> Michael Canva: Did
she ask for a cut?
>> Roz Chast: No, she
was very kind about it.
>> Michael Canva: Okay,
so, urban trail mix.
[Laughter]
>> Roz Chast: Yes.
>> Michael Canva: And
so, you have talked
about how many phobias you have
and how much fear, an entire book
on an A to Z on your phobias.
Is it just a bottomless
well of phobia material?
>> Roz Chast: Yeah, a lot of
things are just very troubling.
>> Michael Canva: Yeah, yeah.
>> Roz Chast: You know, so yeah.
>> Michael Canva: So, pigeon little.
You know.
[ Laughter ]
>> Michael Canva: You've
talked about,
you do a lot of when
you go outside something
about Manhattan inspires you.
Can you talk about that?
>> Roz Chast: I really love
Manhattan a lot it's, you know,
which is why I wrote this
book that's going to come
out on October 4th
called, Going into Town,
which is what my parents used
to call going into Manhattan
from Brooklyn, you know,
we would go into town.
And of course, when I was a kid
we called it going into the city
because Brooklyn wasn't
really the city.
Manhattan was what you meant.
Like when you said you
were going into the city.
I don't know exactly why I loved
it so much from the very beginning.
I think I was just very
distracted from my own, you know,
interior, you know, troubles.
I was trying to explain it to
a friend and sometimes even now
when I get off, you know, I live
outside of New York an hour outside
of New York and when I
get off the train and step
into the street I feel like
just a little anonymous cell
in a bloodstream and the stream
is moving and I'm just kind
of in this bloodstream and I
really like that feeling a lot.
>> Michael Canva: Yeah.
>> Roz Chast: I've never, you
know, fully analyzed why, you know,
why it doesn't cause
me more anxiety,
why I find it sort of calming.
>> Michael Canva: Yeah,
someone should analyze that.
What we talked about, you said
like you're an anxious person.
You went to Connecticut,
you went to the suburbs and,
>> Roz Chast: That makes me anxious.
>> Michael Canva: That
makes you anxious?
>> Roz Chast: Oh god yeah.
>> Michael Canva: But
you get into the thrum
of Manhattan and it allows you.
It frees you.
>> Roz Chast: Yes.
But I think also because
the things in Manhattan
that are anxiety provoking
are things that I know.
Where is in Connecticut, well
there's things like suddenly,
you're in the house and
you hear this weird sound
and it's coming from the basement.
>> Michael Canva: Yeah.
>> Roz Chast: And when you're
in an apartment when you're
in an apartment house
you don't have to think
about what's in the basement.
>> Michael Canva: Yeah.
>> Roz Chast: You know, I know
that there's a boiler down there
but I can like blank
it out of my head.
But when I hear sounds coming from
the basement, in the in a house,
I think it's right under my feet,
so like the house could
sort of, you know, blow up.
[Laughs] I don't know
just terrible smells.
>> Michael Canva: Yeah.
>> Roz Chast: A branch could fall
on the house and break the roof.
>> Michael Canva: Yeah.
[laughs]
>> Roz Chast: You know, I
have a car I mean you're
like the house there's
almost no protection.
Somebody could be driving
down the street,
lose control of the car,
and then BAM the car.
You're like what?
You're in the living room.
I mean it could really happen.
>> Michael Canva: Wow, so how do
you focus enough to do a cartoon
when you're thinking
about all the things
that might befall you while
you're doing the cartoon.
>> Roz Chast: Well, there's
there are medications for that.
There's also caffeine.
And sometimes there are times
when I've had a terrible fear
and then afterwards it
seems really funny to me.
Like one time I was in the
bathtub and I started thinking
about the oldness of our
house and that the bathtub was
on the second floor and that
water was really heavy, [laughs]
and I just started thinking like
do bathtubs ever just kind of,
you know, fall through the floor?
>> Michael Canva: Wow.
>> Roz Chast: And then later
it seemed kind of funny to me.
>> Michael Canva: Yeah.
Has that ever have do you known
anyone that that has happened to?
>> Roz Chast: No, I don't.
I don't know anyone that's happened
to but , you know, things happen.
Somebody, actually this was in
Brooklyn, they were walking,
[laughs] this is so terrible.
[Laughter] and a sinkhole
opened up like just,
[laughing] it was for one leg.
Like one leg just fell
into the sinkhole.
>> Michael Canva: Oh my god.
>> Roz Chast: It just like I saw
it just like kind of gave way.
>> Michael Canva: Ya, but
nothing, no other legs.
>> Roz Chast: No.
>> Michael Canva: That
was the only leg?
[laughing]
>> Roz Chast: Obviously, [inaudible]
he had [laughs] I'm sorry.
He had, this has been a long day.
he had two regular legs [Laughter].
But one of them fell
into the sinkhole.
Oh dear.
>> Michael Canva: We're never
getting through this one.
>> Roz Chast: We're never.
But yeah, I shouldn't be laughing.
>> Michael Canva: No,
[laughs] that's, I love it.
I love to see it.
>> Roz Chast: Yeah,
you should Google it.
>> Michael Canva: So, the
last Thanksgiving from,
again from reality,
>> Roz Chast: Yeah, yes, yes yes.
This is just when you cannot
stand it anymore, you know,
everybody with their , you know,
their things and their needs
and requirements and allergies and
aversions and they're on a special
on a cleanse and, you
know, they have, you know,
their special needs it's and
everybody has a different one.
>> Michael Canva: Yeah, is every one
of us neurotic basically
on some level?
>> Roz Chast: I think so.
>> Michael Canva: Yeah, we are all,
some of us own it, some of us don't.
Around family and turkey
and tryptophan it can fully,
>> Roz Chast: Oh yeah.
>> Michael Canva: So, the
holy trinity, [laughs]
>> Roz Chast: Yeah.
>> Michael Canva: You do some
of the best food humor around.
Just flat out.
>> Roz Chast: Well food is funny.
>> Michael Canva: Food is funny.
>> Roz Chast: I mean,
the whole thing is kind
of funny in a certain way.
>> Michael Canva: From
the sounds and names
to how just we interact with it.
How food means to us.
>> Roz Chast.
Oh absolutely.
I mean the whole thing
sort of hilarious.
>> Michael Canva: Yeah.
And similarly, in the
acquiring of- [laughs].
>> Roz Chast: Yeah, well
there's times where when I'm
in certain moods, and I'm
doing errands in where I live
and I realize that
I'm not in the mode
where I should be talking
to other people.
And, you know, maybe I've been in
my studio for like hours and hours
and hours and then if I don't go
to one of these lines, you know,
some little bee in my
bonnet will say like, "Roz,
talk to other people," and,
you know, make conversation
and then suddenly, you know,
I'm saying something really
awkward and it's just terrible.
>> Michael Canva: Wow.
>> Roz Chast: So yeah.
>> Michael Canva: When
cartoonists talk.
>> Roz Chast: Yeah
that's risking things.
Oh, this cartoon came from was
inspired, this is the gifts
from the house of low goals
and this was actually inspired
by a real ad that I saw.
I was on the train,
the commuter train
and I saw this ad that
was for Carvel.
And it was, you know,
those funny little cakes
and there was there was a
little girl she was 7 years old
with these cute little cat's
eyeglasses and like a party hat on
and she's surrounded by her family
and her grandparents and friends,
and on the cake, is written
congratulations on your new glasses.
[laughs] And I thought,
you know, we really,
you know, this bar is pretty low.
[laughs] So, you know.
>> Michael Canva: I love it.
So, the fountain of puberty.
>> Roz Chast: Yeah.
Well. There's a lot of Fountain
of Youth gangs, you know,
it's a genre in itself but if you've
ever sat outside of a middle school
and watched kids come out.
You know.
>> Michael Canva: There's a lot, ok.
And you do, [laughter].
You do, again your relationship
humor, no one does it better and,
you know, I mean, and part of what
I wanted to get to you, [laughter].
You talked about in Going into Town,
you talk about your
fascination with the visuals.
This sign.
Signage to you is this deeply
engaging hieroglyphics and genealogy
and everything and
you talk about sign.
What do signs mean to you?
>> Roz Chast: Well,
I love New York how,
I say this in the book the
visual density of information.
Everywhere you look, I mean I
suppose that if I knew the names
of different trees aside from
like I think this is a maple
and this may be an elm,
but I'm not sure, you know,
then walking in nature might
be very interesting to me.
But, when I'm in New York I love,
you know, the first level of stores
and then there's like a second
level and then there's the third
and you see oh my god juggling
equipment and it's still there,
you know, like special, you know,
weird underwear or something.
I mean, it's just like millions,
there's millions and millions
and millions of stores
it's like that old SNL skit
with the scotch tape store.
Except it's for real.
There'll be like a story that's
just like scotch tape or ribbons
or whatever and I just love that.
>> Michael Canva: Do you
put actual real signage ever
that you've seen very
specific into your cartoons?
Or is it always with a twist?
>> Roz Chast: It's, you know,
my version of it I guess.
>> Michael Canva: So,
the End of Innocence.
>> Roz Chast: This is an older
cartoon and it was actually inspired
by life and I remember
I was in high school
and I really had a lot
of problems with math.
Especially as it got more towards
like the calculus end of it.
And it was like they were talking
in language I had no idea
what they were talking about.
And I was getting so
wound up about it
and I remember I was
taking this math test
and it was this really
very clear moment
where I thought this doesn't matter.
You know? It just doesn't matter
if I pass this test or not.
It wasn't like I was gonna go to a
special, it wasn't like I had any,
you know, desire to go to
MIT or something like that.
I mean it just didn't matter and
that had never occurred to me before
because possibly, because my parents
were educators and I was brought
up that, you know, if you got below
90 there was something wrong it was
a cry for help , you
know, it was um, you know,
it had never occurred
to me until that moment.
>> Michael Canva: Yeah, that's
it that just didn't matter.
>> Roz Chast: Yeah, that
it just didn't matter.
>> Michael Canva: They
put up the next one.
>> Roz Chast: Okay, [laughter]
>> Michael Canva: And
while we're doing this
and while we're doing this,
we'll have time in a minute
for two questions if anyone
wants to come to the microphone.
Again signage.
You, I'm sorry, you're a
genius and how signs work ,
how we interact with them.
>> Roz Chast: Well, I
think that's one thing
about cartoons that, [laughter] oh.
This this cartoon, I have
a lot of fond memories
of because it was a very
early cartoon that I sold
to The New Yorker and the way
it works at the New Yorker is
that we all submit what we call the
batch and there's about 40 of us,
you know, on staff and we
submit groups of cartoons.
We don't just submit like one
cartoon we submit whatever,
you know, 6, 10, 8,
cartoons every week, sketches
and those are called roughs.
And then if you sell one of the
roughs then you take it home
and you do a finish, and
you do the finished version.
So, this was Lee Lorenz who
is the art the cartoon editor
at the time, aren't editor actually.
He pulled out the sketch
I had done of this cartoon
and he said we're going to buy this
one, but the little flag on the side
of the mailbox, I had it sticking
out like perpendicularly to the box
and attached to the door of the box.
And he said what is that?
And I said well that's the handle.
That's the handle when
you open up the box
and he looked at me like I was nuts.
And then I think he realized
that I had never had one
of those kinds of mailboxes.
[laughs] And this was of course
in the days before Google,
so I just sort of made
up what I thought it was.
Which was the handle with
which you opened the door
or whatever the mailbox
to open it up.
>> Michael Canva: You hadn't
lived in the suburbs yet.
>> Roz Chast: No, I have
never lived in the suburbs.
I always lived in an apartment house
where there were about, you know,
mailboxes and you had your little
key and you, you know, did that.
>> Michael Canva: Mailboxes
and boilers and safe bathtubs.
>> Roz Chast: Yes, yeah exactly.
>> Michael Canva: Can we
take a question right here?
>> Audience Member: Yes, I just like
maybe one comment and a question.
I read the daily comics and the
Sunday colored comics and I must say
that New Yorker has such a,
which are funny sometimes an
interesting and political comments.
But the New Yorker seems they have
so many weird, creative, ideas.
I mean, you must work with
a lot of interesting people.
I mean, I'm not being weird
being bad but, you know,
just more like out of somewhere.
And secondly, what is the difference
to you between a single impact comic
and then the ones in the newspaper,
you know, the newspapers comics
where they're sequential there's
a sequential story as opposed
to the single impact image?
>> Michael Canva: So,
you're being asked
to defend the entire eclectic
system of the New Yorker.
No, I'm teasing.
But there is, you know,
there's that range.
>> Roz Chast: Yeah.
I think it's a different sort
of, well it's most people I know
at the New Yorker who
are cartoonists they,
it's just, you know, it's personal.
It's like your style and
I think that's one thing
that the New Yorker
is sort of known for.
And in fact, I don't think
that most of the cartoons
in The New Yorker are not
terribly, when I think of those kind
of cartoons, I think of them
as kind of very cartoony.
With like googly eyes and like a
big nose and they kind of, to me,
a lot of them look sort of similar.
I'm probably really
wrong about that.
I'm gonna get a lot of hate
mail but one different,
one other big difference
is that with people
who do the sequential thing they
often have characters that repeat,
you know, and I think that my
cartoons have a sort of world
that they come from but
it's not like, you know,
the McGillicuddy's or,
you know, Anne and Mike.
[Laugh]
>> Michael Canva: I
knew they'd come back.
>> Roz Chast: Yeah yeah,
they're always leaving.
[Laughter] It's hilarious.
[Laughter].
Yeah.
>> Audience member: Thank you.
That's interesting.
>> Michael Canva: And by the way,
was this your first
cover, speaking of food.
>> Roz Chast: Yes.
That was the very first cover.
>> Michael Canva: The
history of ice cream.
The family history of
the roots of ice cream.
>> Roz Chast: Yes, I'm so, it's
an evolutionary chart of ice cream
but my father's interpretation
of it was
that it was a doctor telling
you foods you shouldn't eat
because they were bad for you.
[laughter] I know.
>> Michael Canva: You don't try
and explain to your parents.
And you do crochet, right?
>> Roz Chast: Well, it's
really, it's embroidery.
>> Michael Canva: So, this was
literally an embroidered cover?
>> Roz Chast: Literally
an embroidered cover.
>> Michael Canva: Yeah.
>> Roz Chast: Yes.
>> Michael Canva: And
this was very recent.
>> Roz Chast: Yeah it was for
a tech issue and Mother's Day.
[laughs]
>> Michael Canva: What better way?
Who else could have
combined those things.
>> Roz Chast: Yes,
and it's a motherboard
so yeah, it's embroidered.
It was nuts.
I got sort of obsessed
and a lot of fun for me.
>> Michael Canva: Yeah and you
make these brilliant eggs too?
>> Roz Chast: Yeah pysanky eggs.
>> Michael Canva: Yes.
You do a lot.
And speaking of [inaudible
over laughers]
so what we're gonna do quickly,
I knew it would come back
to death rattles in
one way or another.
>> Roz Chast: Yeah it always does.
>> Michael Canva: It always.
So, we'll take one quick question
and then we'll bring
out our next cartoonist.
So please.
>> Audience Member: Hi there,
at the risk of being greedy.
Two quick questions, the first
is if you could talk a little bit
about process, if you work
every day, if you take days off,
how often, for how many hours?
And number two, what illustrators
did you like as a kid specifically?
>> Roz Chast: I work on, the
first question about schedule,
The New Yorker is a weekly magazine,
so I sort of work to deadlines
and I always have other
projects going on.
So, I don't make myself like say,
and I'm going to work six
hours every day or eight hours.
There are days that, you know, I
mean, there's not so much division
between when I'm working
and when I'm not working
because I'm always writing down
ideas, studio time, you know,
everything sort of counts.
I'll be working for hours like, you
know, doing the embroidery thing
or working on the pysanky eggs or
hooking a rug, so, it's just I feel
like with the kind of stuff
that I do the work life
and the not work life really
flow into each other a lot.
And the other question
was, oh when I was a kid.
I loved Charles Adams and
he was the first cartoonist
that I fell big-time in love with
and I also loved Mad
Magazine, Don Martin.
I just thought he was
incredibly hilarious
and Sam Gross and Gay and Wilson.
I read, you know, National Lampoon
all those people, Rick Geary
and of course the underground
cartoonists.
Love them too.
I mean I just I love the form.
I just really love the form.
>> Michael Canva: Yeah well said.
>> This has been a
presentation of the Library
of Congress visit us loc.gov